the iPhone 15 Pro is literally one month
away from launch with September 12th
being the suspected Apple event date but
the biggest leak of all came from
unknowns 21 where he just revealed a
bunch of new exclusive info about the 15
Pro's brand new a17 chip so in this
video I'm actually going to use the info
that he gave us to try and calculate the
expected performance of the new ace17
and see if it matches the leaked
benchmarks that have already come out or
if it's actually going to be a bit of a
disappointment instead so jumping right
into it here's the tweet from Uno's 21
showing that the a17 chip is coming with
six cores for both the CPU and the GPU
now this first part is very interesting
because the current a16 ship has six CPU
cores but only five Graphics cores so
we're getting an extra GPU core which is
great but the CPU layout is staying
being the same with two performance
cores and four efficiency cores which
will be very important for calculating
the performance but moving further into
his tweet he revealed that the clock
speed of the a17s performance cores is
3.70 gigahertz which is actually a bit
less than I expected for a couple of
reasons but before I explain why the
disappointing detail he revealed was
that the a17 will apparently have the
same six gigabytes of the same LP ddr5
Ram as we currently have on the a16 with
no changes at all while everybody was
expecting the switch to 8 gigs so that's
definitely a bit disappointing and it'll
likely lead to a little bit less
performance gains now getting back to
explaining the significance of that 3.7
gigahertz clock speed it's a bit
disappointing considering the fact that
this will be the world's first three
nanometer chip with even smaller
transistors that'll be much more
efficient but it seems like apple isn't
pushing these cores anywhere near their
limits and how do I know well because
that 3.7 gigahertz clock speed is only
6.94 percent higher than the clock speed
of the a16 chip which sat at 3.46
gigahertz however the a16 clock speed
boost compared to the older a15 was
basically the same difference being 6.79
higher than the a15 almost the same
performance boost as we're getting with
the new leaked a17 champ and the reason
that's so important and interesting is
that the a15 and a16 chips are both
essentially five nanometer chips with
the a16 being built with an upgraded
third generation process that tsmc
actually marketed as for nanometer while
not actually being re deal four
nanometer at all it was just 3rd gen 5
nanometer so it's really quite
disappointing to see only a 6.94 clock
speed boost on the new three nanometer
a17 which basically proves that apple is
intentionally limiting the clock speeds
compared to its true potential probably
because they want to save some of that
extra potential for next year's a 18
chip which will also be a three
nanometer chip so what it seems like
apple is essentially doing is splitting
the new three nanometer performance
gains between the two chip generations
to make both the a17 and a 18 seem like
a great jump in performance instead of
pushing the a17 to the limits leaving
Nothing Left Behind for the a18 and
making it look a bit disappointing so
because of that we shouldn't expect
anything too crazy from the a17 and
definitely not as good as the old leaked
a17 chip benchmark work from Tech Reeve
and that's probably why he came out
later and said that the gains are
actually disappointing compared to what
he previously expected so with that said
let's jump into calculating The
Benchmark performance numbers of the a17
bionic chip starting with the CPU side
first before moving on to the graphics
the most important thing you need to
know is that although the a16 chips
clock speed was just 6.79 higher than
the a15 when we compare the actual
performance difference in geekbench 6's
single core test the a16 actually scores
11.15 percent higher than the a15 so the
extra 4.36 percent on top of the clock
speed gains cons from other improvements
like chip design differences cash
upgrades Ram improvements like how the
a16 moved to LP ddr5 from LP ddr4x and
more now as far as calculating the
performance of of the a17 ship we should
definitely expect at least the same
single core gain that we got with the
a16 which was 11.15 percent but because
this three nanometer chip Tech has been
so hyped up I would expect Apple to
redesign the performance cores with even
more cash so if I had to make a
conservative guess I'd put the a17 ship
at being 15 faster than the a16 in
single core that right there gives us a
geekbench 6 single core score of
2890 which is the minimum we should
expect and that's only because the clock
speed difference isn't as high as we
thought especially with tech Reeves
comments on the new three nanometer
chips being a bit disappointing and now
as far as the multi-core performance the
a16 chip was around
16.6 faster than the 815 even though
they both shared the same chip layout of
two performance cores and four
efficiency cores which actually ran at
basically the same clock speed of just
over 2 gigahertz so even with the
e-cores running at the same speed the
clock speed boost of the two performance
cores alongside other cash improvements
led to a 16.6 performance boost which is
pretty impressive but with the new a17
chip I'm expecting Apple to boost the
performance of the efficiency cores
probably up to around 2.2 gigahertz
basically representing a 10 boost in
efficiency core clock speed and because
of that if we wrap everything up
together I'd expect at least a 20
multi-core gain on the a17 ship compared
to the a16 and that's the conservative
guess leaving us with around 7
628 multi-core points making it almost
as fast as Apple's M1 chip in a
smartphone which is insane now if Apple
has more tricks up their sleeve like a
huge boost in cash we could even see up
to a 25 boost but that would put the a17
in line with the M1 which honestly just
seems a bit unrealistic and apple surely
would want to save some of that
potential for next year so sticking to a
20 boost is the most likely outcome and
now with the CPU performance out of the
way let's get into the graphics the most
important new detail to remember is that
the a17 ship will now come with an extra
GPU core up to six total compared to
five on the a16. that right there is
basically 20 percent more cores so
whatever GPU gains we come up with we
need to add 20 no matter what because of
that extra core so right off the bat
let's grab the a16s metal score in
geekbench 6 of 22 292 and add twenty
percent which now gives us twenty six
thousand seven hundred and fifty but on
top of that we're of course expecting
Apple to boost the clock speeds of those
cores as well so let's calculate that
but first there was another very
interesting detail that was confirmed by
geeker one and that's the fact that
Apple literally reused the same exact
GPU from the a15 chip on the new a16 but
they simply overclocked the cores from
3.2 gigahertz to 3.5 which is basically
9.375 higher which ultimately led to a
geekbench six metal score that was 11
faster now the reason Apple reused the
same GPU is because apparently Apple was
planning a fully redesigned GPU with
brand new cores and maybe even Hardware
Ray tracing for the a16 ship but it
wasn't ready on time so they ditched
those plans and they reused the same GPU
from the a15 now this year I'm expecting
those new GPU cores to be ready for the
a17 and I think it would make sense for
Apple to up the clock speeds from 3.5
gigahertz to around 3.8 which represents
an 8.57 boost and since the previous
9.375 clock speed boost on the a16 LED
to an 11 faster metal score we can
probably expect the a17 chips 8.57 clock
speed boost to improve performance
scores by 10 so applying that 10 gain to
the 26 750 metal points that we
calculated including the extra GPU core
we're looking at a final estimated metal
score of 29
425 for the a17 chip so in the end it's
looking like the a17 will be around 32
faster than the a16 which scored 20 22
292 points making the new a17 Chips GPU
almost as fast as the M1 chip which is
super impressive in a smartphone so with
that said those are the conservative
numbers and there's a chance they could
get even better if the new GPU redesign
is a bigger deal than we expected or if
Apple decides to push a bit more
performance into the a17 but just to
recap the numbers once again I'm
predicting a single core score of
2890 a multi-core score of
7628 and a metal score of 29
425 for the new a17 chip so hopefully
you enjoyed this video and if you did
let me know your thoughts on these
performance numbers down below and be
sure to subscribe above and check out my
M3 Max chip calculations video right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next one
[Music]
thank you